[Musique]
1803 Évariste désiré de forge chevalier
puis vicomte de parni né le 6 février
1753 à Saint- Paul inventeur du poème en
prose c'est surtout l'un des plus grand
poète français du 18e siècle envoyé en
France à l'âge de 9 ans pour suivre des
étude il devient militaire après avoir
failli être moine il fréquente alors
d'autres créoles de son âge comme
Antoine Bertin tous aimant la poésie et
les plaisirs de la vie son père le fait
rentrer à Bourbon alors qu'il n'a que 20
ans il y vit une histoire d'amour
contrariée et a en horreur la société
esclavagiste qu'il dénoncera en 1787
dans ses chansons
madcas d'après certains la fille qui
luut avec une esclave serait la
grand-mère de selimen la célèbre
chanteuse de la Saline il quitte
définitivement son île natale en 1776
pour voyager ses poésies érotiques
publiées en 1778 lui valent l'admiration
de Voltaire après des difficultés durant
la période révolutionnaire il profite de
l'arrivée de Bonaparte au pouvoir en
1802 l'année suivante il est élu à
l'Académie
française 18 ariste de par premier
réunionné élu à l'Académie
[Musique]
française